[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news I'm
Heather Bruce and this is your news for
Monday August 13th
first of all wreck-it Ralph has done it
again they released a still from the
movie this week that again featured the
princesses but this time all the
princesses are in some casualwear may be
inspired by vanellope and her
comfortable hoodie so people were just
freaking out about all of these outfits
they look great they fit people's
personalities just perfectly I loved um
Tiana's outfit to see her natural hair
and she's sitting there sipping on some
Starbucks else's graphic tees as just
let it go it's just they have perfect
outfits to match their personalities my
personal favorite was moon lines I
thought Mulan looked awesome with a
jacket and the cuff jeans and the high
tops if you haven't checked it out and
you're a big Disney Princess fan you
should go check that out and let me know
in the comments below what your favorite
casual princess wear outfit was again
mine wasn't a lot it was it just looked
great and honestly there's some really
good opportunities here for maybe some
cross marketing you know there's some
things like her universe or Hot Topic
maybe start picking up and carrying
these shirts for those of us who love
them to buy them yes maybe maybe and
wreck-it Ralph breaks the Internet is
coming out on November 21st so we don't
have to wait too much longer for that
also this week in some video game news
we have some more characters announced
via a promo for Super Smash Bros
ultimate which is crazy because there's
already so many characters involved in
this game but it's specifically focused
on Castlevania so we've got Simon and
Richter now coming in as
characters they're adding a Dracula's
castle stage ello cards gonna be an
assist trophy but the most important
thing that we all took away from this
promo is r.i.p Luigi Luigi was dead well
at least so the internet thought for a
long time for a couple hours there we
were all convinced Luigi's dead I mean
the promo actually shows a Reaper or
someone slashing him his soul getting a
release from his body and then people
were freaking out so much about this
Nintendo had to swoop in and say guys
chill
Luigi's fine he's not dead but who the
internet was very upset about it for per
minute although I still know many of us
are mostly upset about why Luigi not
being included in this game literally
everyone else's where is it Nintendo
where although honestly the game does
look awesome and I cannot wait to play
Super Smash Brothers ultimate although I
guess I should probably work on getting
a switch first whatever this week also
the Oscars announced that they are
adding a new category which okay a
little intriguing but the new category
is going to be best popular film which
honestly seems a little unnecessary and
kind of leanness to me the whole point
here is that the Oscars are trying to
bring in new viewers they've been having
some steady decline in their viewership
and they're trying to figure out how
they can kind of connect with a modern
audience so they're trying to bring in
more blockbuster movies like some of the
superhero movies that have been gaining
popularity recently a lot of people
think maybe this is due to Black Panther
because really Black Panther should be
up there and winning some stuff but it
probably won't be because the Oscars can
be a little elitist sometimes I mean
don't get me wrong I loved shape of
water I saw it I love caramel
Horo and i'm glad that it won but some
people are just feeling like some movies
are getting snuffed that don't need to
be um I think it's just gonna kind of
create more tension or just what would
even qualifies as a popular film is
there gonna be some kind of like
blockbuster status that makes it a
popular film as opposed to a best film
nod although they have said the Academy
has said that it can be nominated a
movie can be nominated for both like
best popular film and best film overall
like it doesn't have to mean that
there's this split line but I really
don't know why else you would create a
separate category except to split the
line and make differentiations I mean
obviously they did that a while ago with
best animated pictures so now you know
there's been it's been a whole separate
category so that animated movies can't
really get nominated for Best Picture
it's just I think it's a dumb move
they've I feel like they've alienated
the audience even more but I'm not part
of the Academy I don't get to say those
things I guess but the Oscars are
premiering this year on February are
happening this year on February 24th if
you care to tune in the category is
being added this year so on the Oscars
this year February 24th will have the
popular films category I'll probably
check it out still anyway but you can
you can make that decision on your own
this week also in casting news first of
all something that I am extremely
excited about Ruby Rose is joining the
CW universe as Batwoman and I think this
is perfect casting as soon as I heard
that announcement I thought she looks
the part we know she can kick butt we
know that she actually went on a talk
show and was saying how she grew up with
her mom actually raising fast so she
feels a little akin to that woman here
and like one of her favorite toys
growing up
were these cardboard bat wings that she
had been made so ruby roses Punk for
this we're all excited to see her play
fat woman at least I am I think she is
just gonna kill it and right now it's
only confirmed that she's going to be
playing fat woman in the crossover so in
December they'll be the flash arrow
legends super girl crossover and that's
initially what bat loin was announced to
be in but now there's some rumors going
around that maybe she'll get her own
show which I mean people are excited
about it
do it CW you've already made like a ton
of other superhero shows let's just
embrace it
bring Ruby Rose and that woman into this
world I think it would be awesome to see
her have her own show as well but you
can see her as Batwoman in December like
I said with the crossover also in
casting news this week we learned some
news about that live-action CGI
sonic crossover that everyone's excited
about um so now we know who's going to
be voicing Sonic
um and Sonic's going to be voiced by Ben
Schwartz who most people probably know
from Parks and Rec he's the worst you
know I think actually this is pretty
good casting um he seems like he's got
the right kind he can have the right
kind of attitude we already know that he
can do voiceover work right now he's
currently playing Dewey in the new
ducktales reboot so we know he can do
some voice work I'm excited for this the
thing I'm not excited for with this
movie besides the weird premise is Jim
Carrey he's playing dr. Robotnik seems
interesting I'm really worried we're
gonna go a little too uh over the top
we're gonna can I just use his name as a
verb we're gonna Jim Carrey the
situation as only Jim Carrey can I just
can't imagine him playing dr. Robotnik
without it becoming like another Grinch
or series of unfortunate events
situations so hopefully I'm wrong and
he's supposed to be live action so Sonic
is going to be cgi and voiced by Ben
Schwartz where as Jim Carrey is going to
be live-action so we can all check out
that possible trainwreck of a movie in
November of next year so November of
2019 that's going to be coming out
lastly this week Sony is celebrating the
fact that they have sold over 500
million units of the ps4 and to
celebrate that they are releasing a
limited-edition blue translucent ps4 Pro
which looks awesome to me I'm a sucker
for those kinds of translucent things so
I might just be getting the controller I
don't need to get a whole new ps4 for it
but that controller looks pretty sweet
it's also gonna have some bronze plating
in it including like a bronze plate on
the front with the number of the unit
since it is limited edition they're only
making fifty thousand of these for
worldwide sales and it goes on sale
August 24th so if you're a big fan and
you're ready for that
get ready August 24th I'm sure they will
sell out like that so anyway that's
gonna be it for me this week let me know
what your thoughts are on these news
stories in the comments below let me
know if you I missed anything that
you're super passionate about let me
know if you're actually gonna go see
that Sonic movie cuz I don't think I
will you can also connect with me on
social media you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or Twitter I stream on
Tuesdays and Thursday
but I hope to see you around and beam me
up
[Applause]
you